The joe rogan experience.
A lot of us get there,
right?
A lot of people that we know came from a place where when they were really
young,
they were like,
what the fuck is going on with the world?
Yep.
Wait,
how old were you?
Do you think you were when you had your first,
Oh,
I think my parents might be fucking crazy thought.
What do you like?
These people are in charge of telling me what to do.
This is nonsense.
You're making you,
you're talking crazy talk here.
It happens.
It happened for me.
Uh,
the first time that I took,
uh,
LSD.
Uh,
and maybe before that,
but when I took Lsd,
I,
when I took LSD for the first time,
I can remember when,
whenever you take Lsd,
uh,
especially,
you know,
I mean,
when I took Lsd,
what worries do I have?
I'm in fucking high school.
There's no,
there's nothing in there.
There's nothing to,
there's no demons to come swimming out of my brain and taught me with like all
the myriad of things you get when you're older.
There's this fucking nothing you would just open.
I'm,
I might be upset cause like a cheerleader that came over to my house,
I couldn't figure out how to kiss her.
Maybe that's like the biggest problem I'm having at the time.
So,
but I,
you know,
at that time when I did it for the first time and had that initial experience,
uh,
you know,
when you go back to your parents who've never taken it,
and if you mentioned it to them that you'd even taken it,
they might want to put you in a drug rehab or they think you're insane or they
think you're getting down the wrong track.
You're forced into this place of like,
fuck man,
I can't,
I w you guys don't even,
you don't even know you,
you don't even understand this,
this a new way of experiencing life,
you know,
so,
and I think there's a lot of people who spend their whole lives never knowing
that you don't have to take psychedelics to get to that place.
There's other ways to get to that place.
But yeah,
it's a very strange thing.
And those people who never get to that place,
they're the ones who are,
a lot of them are,
are in control.
Right.
So your life took a inexorable change when you did acid that was like the point
where you look back and you said,
this is the point where I went off into this direction.
Um,
well I know I'd say that the,
the,
that,
that taking acid started with a series of like books.
It started with contact with like,
you know,
the whole weirdness.
My whole weird weirdness started with,
or as I recall,
it started with me coming upon this book that my mom had called Raja Yoga by
Yogi mature Rocka,
who by the way,
it was never a Yogi was just some English mistake.
Okay.
Mind about being a Yogi.
But it's a fascinating story.
But the book,
uh,
you know,
that was the first time I'd ever read the idea.
They,
you there that you are an observer observing yourself,
that you,
you aren't necessarily the you,
that you think the you,
that can be observed is not you.
You're the observer state,
the mindfulness,
the watch or that's when I,
that's the first time I'd come upon the idea of what that's called,
the amen.
The thing that observes yourself,
you know,
when you,
someone will say,
I'm really mad right now.
The moment you say I'm mad,
you're creating a distinction.
You know,
between the thing that's observing that you're mad.
And the thing that's mad.
So that observer,
that watcher,
that's the thing that,
that mindfulness is what,
you know,
throughout my whole life I try to,
go into that place of observing myself rather than being the thing.
And it's a game that you can play in.
It really is quite helpful with a variety of,
of problems,
especially if you get really angry.
If you get really angry and you can stop yourself and just watch and there's
tools you can use.
In that book.
I remember it said as you walk around,
start thinking he is walking.
That was like one of the tools,
like it's in a book and you're a character in a book.
So when you're going around,
you're like,
you know,
right now he's doing a podcast right now.
He's talking.
And so that's,
these are,
these are activities designed to create this,
like the watcher,
the state of presence of watching.
So that started it.
That led me to like,
you know,
I,
and then I found out about,
you know,
I,
I think I read the electric koolaid acid test,
you know,
about fucking,
uh,
Ken Keyes and the merry pranksters blasting themselves on acid and going to the
world's fair and a bus.
Then I read that shit.
No,
I remember,
wait,
I'll tell you then I'll stop this weird,
weird rant.
I remember now.
Fucking filmstrip that's what it started in my head.
I think I was in fourth grade and they showed us a drug filmstrip remember film
strips new fucking popped up.
This guy like it taught,
there's a guy,
I still remember it to guy in it.
It's a guy in a fucking,
um,
empty apartment and he's curled against the law and the fetal position and it's
an LSD and it looks terrible.
And then the narrator says,
Lsd can make you experience hallucinations,
you can see dragons.
And I remember him saying,
you could see drag is,
I'm like,
I want to see you.
Okay,
that sounds awesome.
Fuck the empty apartment.
The fetal position.
I'll figure it out.
That guy's a pussy.
Like what are you crying?
So dragging a little bit,
it took acid and takes back.
Yeah.
And that was that put it in my head is like,
well you know I think that that's an interesting thing to explore but
yeah.
Yeah.
Oh that's hilarious.
So you think that you were like to Dunkin's like Dunkin one and Dunkin to like
Dunkin one is like regular Dunkin growing up innocent boy.
Sure.
Boom.
Psychedelics and then Dunkin 2.0
yeah.
Yeah that there's definitely a dunk into that.
That happened I'd say.
And then that that Dunkin to change too man.
Cause you,
you know,
as you get older,
the best thing,
there's two great,
the best thing that can happen to use you get knocked off track.
That's the best thing that can happen to you in general.
Cause generally the track you're on has been set for you by people who never got
off their track.
You end up,
you know,
you end up the child of someone decided to have you in their twenties 2122
they're not going to know a lot of stuff.
They're not going to understand the universe that much unless they were like
came from a really good family of like artists are intelligent people.
Chances are they're scared,
hungry,
desperate,
angry.
They don't want to be in the relationship anymore.
They don't want to be monogamous anymore.
The idea of non monogamy to them might just seem insane.
The,
you know,
like who the fuck knows?
But you're born into that planet.
You're,
that's the atmosphere you're born into.
That's what you're breathing when you're first born.
And that can set you on a weird path.
And that's a very sad path that you can get on.
And so hopefully if you're lucky,
you'll come across somebody,
you knocks you off that fucking path.
You know,
I remember the guy who hooked me up with acid.
I remember sitting in the theater of my school cause I was taking,
I was a drama nerd and I sitting in the theater of my school and next to this
guy
next to this Guy Brad.
And uh,
I remember seeing an I and we were talking and he mentioned tripping on Lsd.
And I'm like,
what?
It's like,
oh yeah,
I took acid over the weekend.
I'm like,
well why you can get acid,
the movie,
the life,
the life of somebody must animate this.
Somebody,
the
police.
I know your folks out there that animate shit.
You got to animate this,
that,
that moment took me two,
and this is really weird.
Tell me what the,
the first trip was like.
God,
I love to,
the first trip was it was white blotter,
a white blotter paper.
I,
I don't,
it was just white bladder,
a little Pete,
you know,
somehow if you don't know this,
uh,
LSD gets put on sheets.
Let's just look like blotter paper.
And sometimes they have design,
sometimes they don't.
But the name is always a reference to usually as a reference to the design on
the sheet.
So,
uh,
you know,
purple,
Jesus,
White Blotter of lips.
You know,
there's a million different names for the different types of acid,
but,
so this is just white.
You who knows what it was,
but it was really good and I can remember I took it
and you have to,
you know,
it takes 30 to 45 minutes sometimes longer for it to kick in.
I still remember I was sitting in my friend's trailer in a trailer park in North
Carolina sitting in an empty back,
like when it like an empty Jacuzzi tub that was in this trailer.
And I'm sitting there and they're watching star wars and I'm sitting in this
bathtub and all of a sudden the greatest,
it's the greatest feeling just started going through my legs and up into my
body.
And it was a fucking sword fight.
It was a,
a light saber fight.
Bam,
Bam.
When I'm listening to that.
But all of a sudden now,
the sounds echoey,
like someone's turned an echo up on it.
So I was like,
yeah,
well,
you know,
parents kind of bouncing around.
It's beautiful and I feel so fucking good.
Started laughing.
It seems so funny.
Then I went outside and lay in the grass and staring at the sky.
Everything's beautiful.
You put your hand in front of your face and it's just this rainbow of hands
drifting in front of your face.
Everything's breathing.
They're my friends come running out because they knew this is the first time I
was tripping and they all start jumping over me.
They're like jumping over me is,
I'm low and they're laughing and we're all fucking laughing and it's just
perfect.
Then I remember they pulled their cock out.
That's when they pulled that too.
We all started fucking,
we fucked and fucked and then a dog came by and we grabbed the dog and started
fucking the dog.
No,
no.
It was beautiful to the spirit of acid.
It's very now.
Yeah,
there was no fucking happening.
There was a lot of like laughing.
There was a,
I remember going into my friend's shitty high school car and like sitting in
like pulling the seat back and looking at the ceiling and I'm looking at the
ceiling and it's fucking hieroglyphics or some kind of like ancient writing.
You know,
I don't even think I knew what Sanskrit was at the time,
but I probably be like,
oh,
I'm seeing Stan script some kind of runes are glyphs all over my friend's car
that she's kind of breathing and warping and it's just beautiful.
So yeah,
that was the,
that was the first time.
And,
and once you've had that experience,
how do you go back to a world,
a normal kind of world?
Incredible.
Amazing.
What is it?
It's cursed.
Swale
is a,
they call him a futurist and he's responsible for many,
many patents.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant man.
And um,
he is a huge proponent of the idea of the technological singularity.
And the idea behind that is that one day artificial intelligence is going to
literally and virtually come alive and we're going to merge with it somehow.
We are either going to be downloaded into computers or consciousness is going to
be replicated and indistinguishable from our current consciousness and that will
be downloaded into computers.
And though our biological body will die,
are our electronic signal.
That is our consciousness that has been recreated.
Like,
you know,
like you copy a Microsoft word file.
Yeah.
You will copy your mind,
you will copy your consciousness,
your soul.
Yeah.
You will copy something and you will put it into this whatever the fuck it is
that holds all this stuff.
But what we're saying is that life is almost completely connected to technology
and it's a very,
very short time that this has happened 200 years ago.
There were no cars,
you know,
so in those 200 years we have been connected to cars who was,
um,
a really fascinating video that someone sent me that I put up on Twitter.
I retweeted it the other day.
You can find it if you just scour through my Twitter,
but it's a time lapse video of,
uh,
of cars moving back and forth on freeways and how it looks like blood and the
car.
Yeah.
How it looks like the pulsating of blood coming back and forth.
You know,
I mean it's clearly is the breath of breathing in and breathing out,
you know,
the heartbeats in and out the cars leave the house and come back to that house.
I mean,
it really is.
It really is like,
it's a type of life form.
It's just,
it happens so slowly.
All this traffic sucks.
My Dick,
you know,
on the fucking,
my car's dying shit and all these things that you,
you micro manage that,
that scenario.
And then you don't see it as this pulsating thing of,
of cars coming in and cars going out.
And how many of them go in the same God damn door
every day?
Here's the thing,
man.
And this is where the,
I think about this all the time because the way for,
for things to work,
the way they're working right now,
which is for there to be capitalism in there to be super rich people and super
poor people in war and all the things that you know,
or rather distasteful or seem to be,
uh,
seem to be a destructive for that,
to exist.
Each of those little nodes of consciousness that represent that bloodstream have
to think they're individuals and have to think they're more important than all
the other ones.
So you've got a bunch of blood cells all thinking,
yeah,
I got to get to work.
What the fuck's wrong with this asshole in front of me?
And not realizing they're all part of this one super organism.
And if somehow everyone's consciousness shifted from the idea of like,
I gotta get to work to whatever the next thing would be,
which is I'm connected to this super mind that is the planet,
which I think is going to,
that's what the singularity will be.
It will be some technologically,
uh,
applied empathy that allows everyone to connect their consciousness to mother
earth.
Yeah.
That moment capitalism kind of ceases as we know it and capitalism of course,
it's just a,
it's a symptom of something deeper.
But that,
that model,
the model that's running everything is no longer possible.
And that model encourages a competition model,
encourages people to push and strive and push beyond their comfort in order to,
you know,
to create more action and create more money to create more,
more building,
more construction,
more,
more things,
more wars,
more prisons,
more la,
buying more things,
more diseases.
So we can have more realism.
Yeah.
All of it.
It all accelerates.
They invented diseases.
It's a,
it's a fascinating thing man.
You know,
the,
uh,
the idea that everything moves in the same direction is that the single celled
organisms,
you know,
that,
or even how about we look at blood,
you know,
when you're talking about it looking like a,
like blood moving through arteries,
you know,
blood is a single cell,
single cells of blood move as in the same as this huge animal that has a,
you know,
billions of cells and not just that,
but is also a host for all sorts of bacteria and stuff that live inside of our
bodies.
But we have to,
in order to keep it going in the same direction as those cells,
we have to have all these different little tools that we use sort of justify
existence,
all these different little tools like the love of having your baby,
the love of Orgasms,
you know,
the love of going on stage or of creating something,
and you think about the one thing that's the most satisfying,
you know,
outside of childbirth and in having your own children is creating,
people who don't create things I think as a whole are way less happy than people
who do create things.
And I know dudes that make pool cues.
I know dudes that make belts,
they make custom wallets and there's a something that they get when they like,
you know,
I bought a wallet from this dude and you,
you buy a wallet from him and he sells you the wallet and he made it for you and
shit.
Like there's a smile that he has,
like he created something,
he created a piece of artwork and someone else is appreciating a,
wow,
I love how you did this is wow,
this is awesome work.
It's so clean and well done.
He's like,
thank you.
I like his effort and his,
his creativity have gone into an actual object.
And to us that's very,
very,
very satisfying.
And then there's the comedy satisfaction that you get for performing.
I mean that's all we,
you and I understand.
I mean,
you don't understand it.
I guess it's in music,
it's probably just the same thing.
You create a song and then people love that song creating something.
Then what are you doing when you're creating something while you're doing the
same fucking thing.
You're,
you're pushing the machine,
you're pushing it in your way and your way is making people happy and,
and giving people some positive energy by your DVD.
And there's an industry behind that and they come see what the clubs and this
cause industry behind that.
Even behind putting gas in their cars and you know,
it's,
it's a really,
it's amazing how many different pieces are in place.
If you,
if you take back,
if you like,
you know,
zoom in on the idea of what is creation and creation is taking something from
the nothingness and bringing it into the something that's,
and so you sort of become the doorway for sending that come from the nothingness
into the,
something I said,
when you're creating,
you're actually experiencing a as flow through from the infinite into the finite
and that I think that is the feeling that we love so much is that sense of
feeling that that thing when you're working on jokes and all of a sudden it goes
from being a drudge Tavis sudden it's like,
Holy Shit,
you know,
it's happening.
All of a sudden you get sucked into this weird vacuum and you,
you've written for like two hours and it feels like a second.
You know,
that that sense of being pulled into a momentary current or something's coming
out of you that's clearly not necessarily you.
That to me is like one of the ultimate.
It is,
it's the ultimate feeling.
And I have the,
you know,
I think if you go by this idea of this attractor that Mckenna talks about her,
this thing that exists and hyper hyperspace that it's what it wants to come
through.
I send it this universe that wants to express itself through us.
And um,
I think that's the compulsion that you're talking about.
I think that's an alternative viewpoint obviously.
Um,
there's the cynical way of looking at it like,
no,
no.
That's a natural inclination that people have.
Monkeys are curious.
This is what we do.
We think about things.
And every joke that you have is just,
is a cumulation of your life experiences and you're figuring out a little bit,
congratulations.
You're not tapping into the universal consciousness will be ranked back.
Sarah Pailin is on the line and we're going to have a nice little sit down with
a future president of the United States.
Maybe let's hope he doesn't fuck anybody,
that he's not married to buy imaginary rituals.
The thing about it,
but you know what I'm saying?
The cynical point of view about the idea of creativity.
There's something to that point of view too.
You have to address it.
You can't always go hippie and one of the things I bet I bounced back and forth.
I don't think it is either,
but it is a little,
I bounced back and forth with the idea of the imagination being a,
almost like when you,
when you have imagination,
the imagination is the real force behind the,
the evolution.
What imagination truly is is we think of as like,
oh,
I can see things.
I go and work around problems.
I have this idea.
But when you imagine an idea,
when you imagine a product,
you imagine how to design an engine for a car and you're the for,
you know,
your Henry Ford or whoever the fuck made the first engine.
When you're,
your imagination has this idea for this thing and then you build it and design
it and boom,
it's there.
That thought what there,
there was no thought of that before it existed.
It's not that people were running around thinking of the car and I know it's
going to look like there was no thought of it.
You created this or it came to you.
There was something from nothing,
something from,
from what is that from the ether.
Something from these.
Even if it's just these synapses firing in your mind,
where is,
what is the signal,
what is the root of this signal to be so you know,
mathematical about it and say,
wow,
it's just human ingenuity and that's what it is.
It's good old sticktuitiveness and your roll up your sleeves and yet figure out
this world want that.
Henry Ford created a great thing and you know,
whilst dinner and Tosh,
I understand he was a great fella.
[inaudible] neurons sweating.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't necessarily know it's,
it is possible that the imagination is something that is information that is out
there.
Like the,
the idea of the acacia records,
the idea of uh,
you know,
that there's shit out there.
And then what we are is little antennas and that our,
when we tune into something,
if we pick up this,
this signal for the engine and someone picks it up,
excellent.
Once that piece is in place,
oh,
and then it flowers and blossoms like,
like a Fibonacci sequence on a fucking,
uh,
a sunflower.
You know,
it all bursts out,
you know,
exponentially in certain directions.
And then that starts creating more inventions with all,
which also burst out.
But all of them emanate in the imagination initially.
All of them have to be thought up auto.
All of them have to be created by the human mind or what the human mind can tune
into.
There's no way into this universe as a human,
but through a pussy.
And there's no way.
Now there is no way for an idea to come into this universe except through a
thought.
There's no way for an invention except it to come through our mind.
Our minds are the,
our minds are sort of the creative orifices through which all innovation,
every invention,
every idea comes.
It's through the human mind.
Now,
if you want to think that some day you just wake up and you get in the shower
and you get lucky enough for your neurons to fire a certain way where you figure
out how to reduce the cost of making solar power panels and solve the uh,
you know,
the energy problem on the planet.
If you want to think that that's an accident,
fine.
If it helps you.
It seems like it helps a lot of people to think that the universe springs from
some kind of lightening pole adding plasma or the earth does or humor,
biological life on the earth.
And some people like to think that their neurons get lucky in fire cause they
squeeze their brow together in the right way and popped out an idea.
But I think you'll find that most of the great creators,
they don't think that you know when you write,
but is that because the best way to create is to not think about yourself?
The best way to create is like when you start thinking about yourself,
the ego starts tripping over his own dick and you start thinking about like how
cool you are.
That's like when you see a guy on stage and the guy like obviously thinks she's
cool.
The worst it's the worst is the feeling is a feeling of gross.
Nist is a disconnect and that disconnect also disconnects him from creativity.
Whereas if you see a guy on stage and he's just in the moment,
man,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He's just tuned into it.
So compelling and so interesting.
You know?
So maybe it's a trick,
you know what I'm saying?
Like maybe this idea that you know that we are tuning into the infinite and it
is maybe not,
maybe it just requires a certain state of mind to be creative.
And that state of mine is to avoid the ego.
Like the car.
They don't just invent the car,
you invent the wheel first.
And it's because somebody sat there like,
Hey,
I need to take stone or take heavy thing over here.
You know,
it's,
I understand the intent of the movie.
I think it's also necessity.
Inventions come with necessity certainly is,
but guess what?
Antelopes on event and shit.
They keep getting jacked by Jaguars left and right.
They're stupid fucks.
They never figure it out every year.
They never invented annual mobe car.
Whether you can just give the finger to the Jaguar,
beeped the Horn and run over the Jaguar babies.
They seen the road.
They can't do it.
We can and the one of the reasons why we can is because we're conscious because
we can think and,
but what is thinking?
The real question is what are,
what are all these things firing together,
solving problems.
What is all that really because some people can't solve shit.
There's,
it's very clear that there's a,
there's different types of people.
There's people that are super solvers and there's people that can barely solve
taking a shit and wiping their ass correctly.
There's people that can barely show up for work every day.
Everything they do is a fucking mass and they make more people that are just
like that.
Well if you think that there's an order to the whole thing,
what are those fucks here for?
You know,
are they here just until robots can become invented to do menial tasks?
Is that what it is?
Well yeah.
Here's the thing.
What you do,
this is what you do.
Especially you don't,
you think of an IC eat and when things get bad,
for sure they think of like the greatest idea ever.
And your brains though,
didn't he get mad cow disease where ions will fuck you up.
You can,
if you cannibalize you candidate every the brain,
the brain,
just the legs,
nature,
nature's balls and asshole rates are goes bitch,
you got a problem,
people brains you fucking crazy.
Pella chips are delicious.
If you look at,
if you,
so the idea,
just to get back to this idea of like where do thoughts come from?
Well if you,
if you take things out of the temporal perspective and look at things as some
unified whole,
and by temporal you mean present and future.
Okay.
So let's look at the whole thing is like from the perspective,
if we could jump out of time and we could look at whatever this event was,
let's call it the big bang for now and the series of reactions that happened
directly after the Big Bang and those first few seconds that the people at the
particle accelerators want to understand.
And then you follow that all the way to the condensation of gas,
I guess that made matter.
An event in the galaxies and the Gat.
And then you follow all the way that to the first,
uh,
mix chemical soup that whatever that was.
And then the DNA starts forming out of that.
And then that DNA somehow gets encapsulated in a membrane and we have cells in
the cells gain symbiotic relationships with other sounds and become
multicellular organisms,
which have symbiotic relationships.
And eventually you end up with us.
We still are at basically a DNA trail going all the way back to before DNA to
matter,
all the way back to this explosion of light.
And so a thought is an idea of emerging from infinity,
from the ultimate explosion.
The trillions of years ago and to the present moment.
Now,
if that ain't come in from nowhere,
I don't know what it is.
You can say,
well no,
it's my neurons that did it.
Well,
your neurons did it right now,
but you're a chain of super reactions that led to this moment in time when you
invented the thing you invented,
right.
You know,
you're not just your neurons,
you're connected to that an entire ecosystem and you're connected to a infinite
past,
you know,
and it's just,
I guess when you start looking at things,
it just,
you know,
there's your 60 year lifespan,
I suppose things can start looking pretty grim and Penn and teller nourish.
But if you really just step out of time and really look at what's going down,
it's like,
it's fucking crazy,
man.
We got blasted out of some infinite passed and we're like yapping about it right
now.
It
really,
it just keeps going over and over and over and over and over and over again.
Can I tell you my new theory of reincarnation?
Yes.
And it's really intense because I thought at this and it freaked me out.
It's pretty horrible.
So it's like that common idea of reincarnation.
If you subscribe to the theory is that you die and you're born again.
You go through your childhood,
did you grow up and then you die.
Maybe you get born as a cat,
maybe a butterfly,
right?
Maybe an Amoeba.
This is what I was thinking.
Cause I had a dream once and in this dream I was a kid,
a little girl,
and my mom was rubbing my head and I knew I was dying,
but I didn't know what that meant except I knew it was bad and I could kind of
feel myself fading out.
There was this like white sort of thing happening and then I woke up out of the
dream like,
fuck,
what is shitty dream?
So I was thinking like,
Oh fuck,
what if that's what reincarnation is.
What if when you die,
you know when you're driving home one night,
you've had too many part lollipops.
You're listening to coast to coast.
Someone says something shocking that makes you look away from the road.
You swerve off,
you slam into a tree,
you wake up,
you're here back in your house like,
Oh fuck,
what is shitty dream,
but you've really died.
You just re-incarnated again into an ultimate reality,
an alternate reality,
so you literally can't die.
There's no break.
This just goes on forever and ever and ever and ever.
No break,
no stopping,
no new age.
Going into the light and seeing your parents and your family and taking a,
going into some new age,
a cosmic spa where you get to shake off all your shitty Karma.
It never stops.
It just keeps happening again.
Again,
maybe like right now there's an earthquake and the ceiling collapses and all of
a sudden you're just some daydreaming cabby and Boston like,
wow,
that was fucking weird.
I was just imagining I was a comedian in la,
but you know what I mean?
Well,
that's bizarre.
You're going to change lives.
You just snap and do another [inaudible] become the guy rides his body out.
Yeah.
You snap into an alternate life with all your
memories embedded,
everything already embedded in there because it's an infinite,
it's an infinite,
this,
the,
Oh,
it goes on forever.
What if your consciousness is living a bunch of different lives simultaneously
and you just can't,
you can't see them.
Yeah.
It's like a,
an office filled with cubicles and no one's poking their head over the top of
the cubicle.
Yeah,
right.
We're all rolling at the same time.
Yeah.
Or like the way I thought about it is like if you're,
if there was like some,
this,
it sounds really crazy,
but imagine that each of your fingers,
it sounds insane,
but imagine like each of your fingers had their own personality and their own
like consciousness or something.
It's like,
and you could stick them through some kind of hole where they would forget they
were attached to your hand and they would just think that they were their own
individual selves.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe that's what we are.
We're just like little fingers protruding into this dimension from some infinite
thing.
But the product of protruding into this dimension as we get instantaneous
amnesia and part of like dealing with a shock of coming into this dimension is
we forget our true identity and replace it with our ego structure.
Good.
We'll do it a four minutes and 14 seconds.
We'll just end this because it's fascinating.
By the way,
I'm not dissing this guy at all and I fucking love this music and I love,
I love his song and I love that kind of music.
I like it a lot.
Toby Keith Song,
I don't have anything wrong.
A patriotic songs at the end of it,
listen to sky does this little speech and this is like this old old dude that's
like,
hello my country.
I love my guns,
I love my payment,
I left the way it is now and anybody that tried to change it has to come
through.
Mate,
I should be on our head.
Jeez is this is America and a country boy is good enough from make sense?
Okay,
play that back again because that might be a terrorist message.
Okay.
That re retarded fucking
speech.
Back it up.
Read it.
Listeners listen to us.
Is that a bag?
Listen,
I love my country.
I love my guns.
I love my family.
I left the way it is now and anybody that tried to change it has to come through
me.
That's for music or entity.
That should be all of our answers.
That's this is America and a cut.
Your goal is good enough to make
country boys good enough for me.
Like we are as evolved as I need.
Let's stop right here.
Anybody else talk and if you can listen to a cancer cell.
That's what I sound like.
It's just so fucking stupid.
It's like a little more guns.
Oh,
that's you.
I love my country.
I love my guns.
Oh Jesus.
Dude.
Just hurry up and die when you fucking hurry up.
You fucking modeled t human being.
You dip shit.
Just die.
Oh,
love my family.
I love my guns.
Broad troughs.
Take those.
They'll come to me.
I'll take a look.
I'm not saying I don't want to take your guns,
dude.
All right.
I don't want to talk about guns too.
I love my family too.
All right.
Settle the fuck down every time in history,
Christ,
every time in history,
no one's coming through you,
bro.
But every period in history,
he's got those human anchors desperately trying to dig their claws into that
fucking in into the earth and keep evolution from happening.
Desperately.
Fight.
They'll kill for it.
They'll kill for acquisition.
What do you mean?
Wait a minute.
You can't be serious.
Do you?
Everyone gathered round.
Did you hear Galileo?
Did you hear what Galileo just said?
Father,
he said that hurt.
He speak.
I love my earth in the center of the universe.
Earth.
I love my sticks and bows and arrows.
I love,
I love Burt's ears.
I love my slang.
I love my slave.
I love my love.
Hornen,
which is anybody tried to take my catapult away.
I'll come through me.
I love my scroll.
I love my car.
I love carving in rock.
Oh,
I love walking.
I don't need to ride any horses.
I don't need domesticated animals.
That's complicated.
Nobody wants to domesticate.
Horse has got to come through me.
I love being a hunter gatherer.
I love having a lifespan of a single cell organisms.
We're all having a good time down here at the bottom of the ocean floor.
Anybody wants to change that?
It's got to come through me.
I love being a carbon molecule.
I love exists in the pre big bang conditions.
Hello family 11 but it wants
to change that.